[Music]
thank you very much for joining me for a
lovely I guess really foggy Thursday
morning my name is Ilsan Lee I'm a
product manager with the Google cloud
I'm actually based in New York so I have
to fly out here and thank you for coming
for joining us to talk about the new
crypto key storage options for the
Google cloud platform I just want to ask
people here so how many people here care
about crypto ok so you guys are all the
right rooms so that's fantastic that's a
great start
what I like to talk about in this talk
right now is that I'd like to start
talking about the new key storage
options so we're going to provide with
with the Google cloud platform now how
many people think they know what the new
key storage option is going to be like
anyone have a guess ok so say Justin so
you guys were listening so fantastic I
want to tell you this is really really
thrilling for me to be up here to be
able to talk about this you know for so
long I've had to actually talk you know
not talk about this and tell people I
work on something that I can't tell you
about and clean my wife and then my wife
I keep asking I tell her that I can't
tell you and now I can tell her and
she's like I don't understand and so
hopefully hopefully you guys can
understand a little better than my wife
can't so that'd be fantastic
I'll also talk listen your key types and
capabilities that we can do and then
we'll just start generally discussing
things around how to help satisfy the
clients requirements what we're talking
about and how to help me internal
security requirements all right does
that sound good all right cool so let us
start off with kind of an overview we
always do these overviews and I promised
to make this as least painful as
possible but I if you've ever talked to
me before and I'm Dennis yes I did I
work in New York I am the product
manager for a lot of key management in
the cloud and so I've talked to probably
some of you at least and discuss you
know some of the current key management
options so if you take a look at this
scale you have that scale of controller
keys and on the far right side you have
you have no real control and on the far
left side Google really has no real
controller keys so there are
on the far right or left side I'm sorry
the default encryption that's thing
where we provide you with the encryption
of your data arrests whether you want it
or not now we're a little bit you know
like authoritarian that way but you guys
don't have a choice when you put the
data up into the our cloud it has to be
encrypted
we don't really allow you not to encrypt
it and so what happens is that you're
putting your data up to the cloud we
have this elaborate system by which we
break up your data we shard it or break
into chunks and then we we individually
create random encryption keys for each
single one and those encryption keys can
regenerate
every time yep that the update that data
and they get sprayed out to the data
center so if you tend to talk that Maya
and I did yesterday we talked a little
bit more about this so I won't go too
much into it but you know the the keys
that actually that protect you chills
chunks is protected through a key that's
in our internal kms system that's
particularly through elaborate key
system and I think the thing I said
yesterday was that ultimately that he
actually gets stored in physical media
and kissed a complete global disaster
and it's known by 20 or less people on
Google I believe and I'm not one of them
so if you try to come and sort me then I
know nothing now
the next thing on that list is that if
you want go live in more into control we
have Cal kms and this is where it's
basically external stanchion of our kms
system so we're now providing you with
the capabilities of actually creating an
aes 256 symmetric key to do encryption
of the data right I mean you can do
creation deletion rotation all the
things you expect to do in addition to
that we've been integrating this with
various different services or so-called
customer management christian keys and
then next to that we have the customer
supplied encryption keys if you really
want to have more control over your keys
and that's it's in that feature we
actually don't keep your keys at all so
when you actually put data up and up in
your GCS bucket for example then you
need to provide a secret that we use to
help encrypt the data and then every
time you want to access that data you
have to be provide it and we use that
secret to help decrypt the data and then
we get rid of it it never gets stored
anywhere it definitely doesn't go in to
disk it's only in memory so it's
something that's available
yes in GCE but not for other services
one of the main problems is is that when
we say we don't keep the key we really
don't keep the key right and so if you
lose a key there's absolutely nothing we
can do about it and if you don't provide
the key there's really nothing we can do
about your data so for services that
require us to do background operations
such as you know like compaction for
example which is some of the services do
we can't help you because those things
are going to fail we don't have the key
to do that so as a result it's only
available for GCE and GCS and will
likely not go beyond that then finally
on the far right side and this is
something that some people have done
I've see some people here who might have
done this but basically this is where
you want to keep your own keys in your
own device that you want to have you
know complete control over and assurance
and everything else and so you will
provide the hsm and will help you host
it somewhere close to one of our data
centers okay and you know we can help
set up the high-speed interconnect
provide a super low latency connection
to us obviously the downside to this is
that you are still responsible for dream
you know buying the devices you have to
still operate them okay you have to make
sure that you know they're all cluster
eyes everything else and that your
application will basically connect
directly to it right so you're not
really leveraging a cloud services
directly for this all right oh and feel
free to ask any questions as I go along
the way and if you feel like using a mic
go ahead otherwise just shout it out so
now I'd like to introduce cloud hsm I
know the thing that my wife doesn't
really understand but you know I tried
so this guy fits right in the middle of
the scale right so it gives you a little
more controller keys or kms in the sense
that you now have a service where it's
protected by a hardware security module
how many people here know what at HSN is
well you guys are awesome yeah so you
know they give you the assurance --is of
what at HSM provides right so you know
we can't get the key material I mean all
things like that uh be bound to the
hardware
and it basically gives you more options
now for your kms so let's start off with
you know it's not like most of you guys
know about this but this kind of indulge
me and I'll just try and make sure
everyone's kind of level set and explain
what HSN is so an HSM is a hardware
security module right so it basically is
a physical device for managing and
performing matching keys and perform
encrypt operations does a little bit
more than that but essentially that's
what's really useful and people would
like these things largely because they
can create keys are Knox portable the
hardware will provide some guarantees
that once you create the key inside this
thing it's not exportable kind of right
I mean the vendors like to allow the
keys to move around between their own
devices but you know you can't export
anything else
and then they're often temporary provide
tamper evidence and tamper resistance so
if you try to break into one these
things then they're saying that they'll
probably be able to notice and they'll
record it and if you actually try to
compromise and you get close then it'll
do things like zero all the keys so the
keys are completely wiping the system
right and the other thing is I said they
come with 51-42 certification and yeah
please sorry well the fifth level three
fifth one for level three dictates some
other conditions around what you have to
provide and such HSM typically provided
level 2 or level 3 right yeah and I'll
talk a little bit more about this as
well for our service but you know this
certification is important it's it's a
it's a certification that comes out by
NIST you know in the US government it's
the only real good certification that's
available for crypto modules and that's
what it defines so as a result a lot of
people depend upon you know using Phipps
as a kind of gauge to whether this is
adequately implemented or not right and
so again like like ask for level one you
can do this with software typically for
anything breathe and bad you need a
hardware module like an HSN now in terms
of main use cases a lot of people use
this for regulatory compliance right so
if you're doing things like you know
your
the financial industry maybe the
healthcare you do some payments things
like that you likely do you require to
have something that actually has some
high bar around protection of keys maybe
you have specific NIST FIPS requirements
then you know these HSMs become
extremely valuable and the other thing
is that you know whether it's right or
wrong people people feel more safe with
point their keys and hardware but
hardware devices because of some of the
properties I listed before and so if you
have high value keys for example like
perhaps a keys for your top top sign sir
then you may want to put into an HSN
just to make sure that you have that
extra assurance that they're protected
okay makes sense
you guys now know as much as I do about
HSN's so you can that's great
now what's Cloud HSM so cloud HSM is
basically taking the HSM s and making
into a managed service right and when I
say managed I like to kind of clarify
what Google's definition of managed is
so managed means that basically we do
everything for you the only thing you
have to worry about this API right this
- you know for doing the logical
application level of API interaction so
when we imagine it means that you don't
have to worry about any of the hardware
or the infrastructure or anything else
like that at all okay we'll make sure
that you know the patching of the
hardware is all done by us if there's
any kind of veil ability concerns we've
fully clustered everything we have a we
have a very smart layer that actually
make sure is that it's available if
they're scaling issues weak auto scale
we just basically you know restart
that's really interesting story yeah we
basically are able to scale pretty much
horizontally with any kind of workload
that you bring along right so there's no
concerns around that and they're also
rooted in physical hsn's so the key
material is not available outside of
hsn's which means that you can't get
access to the key material but neither
can we okay and if you take a look at
that diagram there the way that you
think about this is that the cloud HSN
feature actually leverages the Zak same
API front-end as cloud kms so if you're
familiar with cloud kms and I'll show
you in a demo later on it's actually as
simple as just flipping a flag when you
create the key and also
everything else that you have in terms
of the api's you use the client
libraries this works right except that
you know the keys are in HSN and I also
explained to you in a demo about how we
actually prove to you that the keys are
actually in the physical device okay so
in the diagram here going back to that
when a request comes in from a client
they go to the kms service and the kms
service knows that this key belongs to
is a software key so we go down to the
software key back-end we do the
operations there or if it's a hardware
key then all the requests get routed to
to the hardware layer which actually
goes to individual harbor node now we
obviously do some smart logic there in
terms of in terms of you know picking
the right node and in that case all the
crypt operations and all the key
creations and everything else actually
happened right in the hardware ok it's
not that we're doing the software these
things actually having the software I
mean the hardware now why should you use
cloud HSN again I'll say us a lot
because this is what a lot of customers
care about but you know compliance comes
up very very very often right so if you
have a good clients need where they're
you know you want or not it's gonna come
up again now regionalization is another
really really cool feature that we
provide as part of this part of the new
product so if you create a key within a
cloud cloud at HSN then that key is
actually cryptographically bound to the
hardware devices within that region okay
so suppose I go and create a key and US
central one those hardware devices in
u.s. central one or the only ones are
able to use our crypto key okay and so
you know the way that we have things
architecture right now is that the keys
are always stored in one of our one of
our highly available file systems and
those things can actually you know move
the keys around and in fact we don't
provide any guarantees around the
location of those of those store keys
but the keys themselves are protected by
the HSM well the least HSM keys so they
can only be used a rat unwrapped and
used by those HSN HSM sent different
region cannot use them okay we will
right now the eight cloud HSM feature is
currently an alpha soon to go into beta
and right now we're looking at
but we will be we will be releasing the
beta across United States and then
slowly started rolling out globally so
this is something that you should be
able to see around the world yes please
the question is whether the same
regionalization guarantees happen with
KMS keys regular KMS keys that sir is no
right so the cloud came as keys when you
actually create the keys in a certain
region they'll be very likely surf in
that region but the system in order to
provide availability or you know to you
know suppose that to know a certain
region goes down it is able to serve
that key from different regions if
necessary yes please yeah so the
question is that meet does that mean
that with cloudy HSN we don't get
availability across regions that's
actually my next bullet so we right now
we're in run region because we're in the
Alpha and then beta will come up with
more regions but we will actually
provide the support from multi regions
right so this means that just like
calcloud KMS right now will have a
global region and we will have a US
region Europe region and Asia region and
what these multi regions mean is that
when you create a key within for example
the US region then that key can actually
be served out of any of the HSMs within
those multiple regions okay so it's up
to you you can actually choose how
granular you want this over there please
oh sure I'm sorry so the question is can
we explain the context of alpha so alpha
4 for us is a generally not always by
close release right so we have a subset
of people who are actually using it
they're testing and providing some you
know close interactive feedback and then
when we get to beta beta is the point at
which we actually release it publicly
where we will provide you know full
support for the product we'll provide
you know like you know you can actually
put production workloads and everything
on it the one thing that we don't
necessary
until we go generally available is SLA
yes the question is whether anything
that the features are worth mentioning
right now would be cut from the beta no
no that's just no everything that I'm
talking about here is definitely stuff
that we will be providing and the beta
question so yeah question is when will
HSN Street globally available I can't
answer that right now because it depends
upon schedule around you know when we
can actually start deploying the
hardware to other things the cloud HSN
has been a very interesting interesting
project least for my career because it's
not only a software but there's a strong
hardware component to it right and so
since especially since we're stealing
with the cryptographic devices well
there's some increased sensitivity so
what we will do is that we will actually
start rolling these things out depending
upon what our Hardware operations
schedule and everything else is and
we'll have to figure this out but I
don't have that answer right now
yes that's a good question so the
question is whether the cloud HSM is is
a partition or shared partition we don't
follow the traditional model that you
may be used to from using a regular hsm
we're not providing you with a dedicated
partition basically there's you know
it's it's a multi tenant service right
so the only tenant for these hsn's is
Google and we will manage the separation
of your keys and everything else for you
right and you know this is a little bit
of a difference from the way that things
happen from your original traditional
model but what this allows us to do is
that allows us to develop extremely
flexible and scalable type of service
right that allows us to provide this
fully managed type of features that you
know we hope that you'll enjoy all right
next slide so now I want to talk a
little bit about the key features so
three things I want to point out
specifically I want to talk a little bit
about asymmetric keys and I think pretty
much everyone here should understand
what that is statement add to station'
right this is basically the validation
that you know you have a key in the hsm
and then CMAC or customer magic
encryption key integration okay let me
talk about each one of these
individually so asymmetric keys
up till now kms has only provided
support for symmetric keys so you had
one choice you can do a s 256 to crypt
data the envelope encryption or do
encryption with other services but that
doesn't cover all use cases necessarily
and so now we're gonna allow you to
actually create different types of
asymmetric keys and support things like
code signing this comes up every so
often people want to sign certain things
and they want to make sure that the
signing keys reside in the hsm itself
right it's very very typical and it
makes a lot of sense and certificate
authorities as well I mean if you're if
you work for an enterprise then chances
are that you know for example you have
internal non-authoritative CAS and
they're probably doing things like
dishing out x.509 certificates to all
your laptops and everything else that
happens in your in your enterprise and
so that's something where you can
actually take those valuable keys or the
root keys and stick them into an into
our cloud HSM now we've are providing
different types of keys and key sizes
for signature verification so as you can
see there we provide RSA 2 K 3 K + + 4 K
keys in addition we support a couple of
elliptic curve with two different types
of NIST curves so P 256 and P 3 for now
for decryption purposes you can't you
can't actually use RSA keys for
decryption so if you choose to actually
decide that I want to do some kind of
you know PKI type environment and that's
available for you as well
and I won't put that there's a box right
that on the bottom right corner that
this is also available for cloud kms in
the software so everything that I've
discussed here in terms of asymmetric
keys you're free to do this as well in
the software if you choose to this to
you something that's you know more
globally distributed and and cheaper and
faster
okay and your question about that all
right cool
now statement attestation this is where
we provide you with the confidence your
keys were actually created in the hsm
itself right not that you know we could
always say that yes please trust us but
we thought that you guys might feel a
little bit better about being able to
trust something more than this
our my word for standing up here on on
this pistol so what the the stimulus
station is is that it's a
cryptographically signed statement from
the actual HSM hardware and we're not
using any kind of Google developed or
own
I mean branded Hardware where you
actually third-party hardware that's
created by a third party manufacturer
and so the device itself will provide
you with a cryptographically signed
statement that says that this key was
actually created within our Hardware
boundary within the FIPS boundary okay
we'll just probably something important
yes the question is can we share it
without third-party HSN manufacturers
it's caveum Cap'n there's no point in
trying to like not say because when you
actually look at that at station
statement you're going to see the
signature and you're going to see that
it's not a Google sitting sure right now
this thing sure can actually be I'm
really sorry I'm not sure I'll tell you
I'll tell you what it is my I'm doing
demo on this laptop later and they told
me that in order to keep the screen from
locking that should play YouTube in the
background so I have Schubert running in
the background case you're wondering
what that was okay well it talks not
going that badly yet so we'll see so
that statement attestation can be
verified manually ok the manufacturer
will publish the the format of what that
is tisha steamy it looks like and we
will provide scripts that you can
download they'll just be Python scripts
you know fully you can take a look at it
and make sure it doesn't just say printf
everything's okay right so you know you
can download those and you can use this
to actually add verify key attributes
and speaking of that
I'm going to go and give you demo this
right now where I'll show you how to go
and create a symmetric key and verify
that it actually was an asymmetric key
and HSN so if you wouldn't mind switch
it to my laptop okay so can you guys see
this or is this too small is that there
yeah I wish there was a quick option for
Mugu but you know what let me just do
this way so is that better for everyone
can you guys see all right so I create a
keyring I already did this because I
didn't want to step through everything
from his glory in his gory details but I
created keyring US central one which is
where our current alpha hsn's are staged
and so this is actually one other
preface is that this is the alpha UI the
beta UI is very very similar but it's a
little bit different but it's not
marginally different that you're going
to be confused so you know I'm going to
create the key and you'll notice right
away if you're familiar with cloud
canvas already that things are a little
bit different now right so I'll create a
key that says you know like HSN demo key
one okay and I now have the choice of
actually choosing different types of key
purposes so I can choose a symmetric key
which is a default or I could create an
asymmetric key with for our our RSA HMH
of Kieffer's signing or I can create an
RSA asymmetric key for decryption so
encryption decryption or EC key so let's
create an RSA key and you know then he
gives you the option to choose different
types there's a bug in the UI there
should also be a 3k key listed there as
well but you can choose to K for K and
then you have one one other option which
is a protection level this is a key this
is where you can actually say that I
want to go and create the HSN key and so
that's all you have to do yes question
yeah please
it's it depends it depends on know this
is on the perky basis right so if you
choose to and I'll show you a demo on
this later but when you actually
associate the key with for example a GCS
bucket then regardless of how many
buckets you protect with it it's charged
on the Capri key basis sure sure no
problem alright so you know I chose
protection level hsm and then I created
right and I've already created a ton of
these keys so that's why it's kind of
busy over here but you can see here that
which one was a when I created yeah it
just sent demo key right and then we'll
keep one there so you can see right
there that it actually create the key
and it says that's a symmetric key using
RSA signing if you click into this you
know it comes up with the key versions
enabled now one other thing I want to
point out here is that if you look down
at the bottom you'll see that the
there's a couple more options now so you
can't really see it I'm sorry but
there's a get public key option and
right beneath that if you can get past
the letters overhead it actually says
get a station so that's where you can
download the attestation statement and
you can also do this through the the
g-cloud command so let me just do it
through g-cloud and i'll show you a
quick demo after this thing connects
okay so what I'm going to show you is
I'm going to show you a script that's
gonna kind of walk through this rather
than see you guys know type on stage and
make mistakes I want to show you through
a script how things work essentially and
I'll walk you through doing a signing
operation plus I'll show you how I
should validate to add a station okay so
if you look here so now we're what we're
going to do is we are going to create
sorry we're going to go create a AEC ec3
for key and so you can see that
right here right that's one of the
options and it's got a purpose of ICI
signatures right and so that's gonna get
created okay so the next thing we're
going to do is that we're going to
retrieve the public key okay so a simple
thing to do and also the other thing I
should mention is we're going to create
the key we actually request the
attestation file that's what the - - add
station follows and then the next thing
is that we actually just request a
public key and so that's going to
download that as well right and there's
a public key it's base64 encoded right
so a next thing we do is we just create
some dummy data right so foo and some
file and what we're gonna do now is that
we're gonna go and call the HSN to
actually go and sign the key right I'm
not sorry sign the data and so in this
case we're using the key C key that we
just created and passing it the data now
it's gonna come back with a JSON file
and the JSON file you know provides one
of the fields called signature so this
right here is the base64 encoded
signature now my apologies to people in
the back but you don't really need to
see what the actual values are obviously
right it's this base64 encoded of
Accenture and so right now the next
thing I'm gonna do is that I'm going to
actually extract that I put that
sanction to a file and then I'm gonna
use open SSL right so the open SSL is
now running locally and it's gonna
verify that that signature corresponds
to the data that we designed right and
hopefully it says verified okay it says
verified okay so the signature that we
generate with HS HSN cloud HSM
corresponds to what open SSL just
verified now now that we've done that
let's just say that we want to make sure
that we're actually using the property
proper key in the HSM and we want to
make sure that it's not some software
key so we have that out of station file
that we just downloaded right and what
this Python script that you can download
off the the web does is that it actually
takes this this set of us asserts this
cert bundle it actually verifies that
the sensor is associated with the
attestation statement corresponds with
what the search in the cert bundle
kinda makes sense okay
and oh sorry I have to oh I did install
the Python Python handler for open SSL
so we'll skip that for now but
essentially what that comes back with it
says it's verified ok and then the next
thing we have is that we can actually
query the different attributes within
the data station statement and so if you
if you look through and I just want to
point out a few things is that there's a
lot of things here I'll geez I hope you
guys can see there you go okay there's a
few things I want to kind of point out
here one is that if you look at this
there's an ID field here this ID field
is basically a concatenation of a random
string plus the SHA hash of the actual
key ID right so you can verify that by
matching the two together and actually
the script will help you do that and
then there's a ek CV that's a public key
that's a hash shell 256 of the public
key itself so you've already download
the public key you can verify the hash
against what HSM is reporting and this
gives you a nice cryptograph least wrong
way of actually validating that they
correspond with each other right and
this is something you can obviously do
only for a symmetric keys one other
thing I want to point out here is that
if you look in the private key
attestation statement a section there is
a fuel called extractable right right
there and it's set to zero and what
that's saying is that the HSM is
confirming that the key is not
exportable so we now have proof directly
from the hardware that the key that
you're trying to refer to is actually
not extractable as well yeah please
the actual which one the attestation
stamie because you can download that a
station teammate anytime you like yeah
you don't have to do it right a key
creation the other thing is is that you
can also use this to actually help
validate that that's that the the
resource name matches what was reported
in that a station statement and the
Python script your helps it helps you do
this and so it verified here that the
keys match an attestation and another
thing they'll do is that
match that the public key that you've
downloaded matches the hash that you
send out of station statement as well
right
and so you can do that as well and it
comes back and says that it matched okay
so this is a really really cool way of
actually you know especially if you're
if you're a crypto nerd to be really
secure and really really feel
comfortable with the fact that I am
actually talking to the to the hardware
device I'm talking I'm using a key that
I think I'm using alright yeah question
so the question is whether there'll be
any kind of integration with you be keys
or any kind of personal integration with
cloud is you some if you're talking
about doing things like being able to
like bring your keys up and put it to
store them into the HSN and such then
that is something that we're we're
strongly looking at we don't have
anything available right now but if this
is something that's interested you
please come up later and look and we can
chat a little more yes
the question is whether this will be
supported in a mobile device this is a
cloud service so you long as you can
access it through the internet you can
access it anytime you like well that's
the question is what because this is HSN
whether we need a physical connection
now the whole point of the cloud HSN is
that we're providing a cloud feature so
we're backing it using hardware devices
that we're putting into our data center
but we're exposing it as a cloud service
so basically it's a web endpoint for you
ok question the question is can you use
the same RSA key for both encryption and
signing no you can't the way that is set
up is that you need to actually state
the intention of the key when you
initially create it right so the comment
is is that you can use usually use the
same key for for example email for doing
both signing and encryption that is true
the way that we've designed this right
now is that we we want to make an
explicit intention around to know what
the keys are used for so that we can
actually limit the scope of what the
keys can do if there's a reason that you
think that we should be able to support
both with the same key then I'm very
happy to hear this and we can talk about
this in the future yeah thank you
yeah please
so the question is whether the the
asymmetric software keys or GA or
hotness or if they're out or what's the
status currently right now they are in
the same situations cloudy HSM they're
in alpha and so when cloud HSM becomes
available in beta and becomes public you
can expect to see the asymmetric keys
being available and software as well
okay alright so that's that's that was a
demo actually for just showing that you
out of stations and making sure that you
know we can actually prove this is there
any questions around the dental alright
can we switch back to slides please
thank you yes please I'm sorry is the
tool or is that paid service do you mean
the the Python scripts so the Python
scripts that we use to actually verify
it's not it's not gonna be a paid tool
it's it may be gonna be something that
we're gonna allow you to freely download
and it'll be something that will be
published on the web where there'll be a
link for you to download yeah so the
question is whether the actual process
of generating key and verifying is a
paid service yes so cloudy HSM will be a
paid service just like cloud kms is so
you can you'll be charged to do the
signing operation but the verification
service operation that showed you was
actually done on local local client
using open SSL so that's something that
you would do on your side ok I we've not
yet heard anyone who had a valid reason
for doing verification on the HSN itself
but you know it didn't quite make sense
to us but if there is that I'd love to
hear it because I it eluded us so far
not even Federer have environments
that's true because typically you don't
have those signature verifications
happen outside the the signing operation
is the thing that's really really
important yes
the question is whether that I
envisioned this for enterprise and
personal oh I see so the question is
where I would envision someone who uses
it for personal use perhaps you know I
gotta be quite honest I haven't heard of
a lot of people who really feel like
using HSMs for personal use right
there's typically not anyone who has a
personal reason to have something that's
very very secure like this now that
being said you know this is a managed
API it's on a per user basis so if all
you're doing is using like creating
single key and doing a few operations
it's not gonna cost very much at all
right and so you're perfectly welcome to
do that but I've only met one person I
know that plays with HSN for fun it's
one of our PM's he works our Kirkland
and he likes to buy them off he being
has a whole garage full of them and I
just I don't know I don't think there's
something right in his head but you know
I think that he because no one does that
for fun right but you know I envision
that you know this will be very popular
with lot of enterprise users users for
personal users I can see it if you need
to do something like you know you want
to host your search for example and you
need to actually just you just want to
make sure that's something you feel a
little more secure about because there's
nothing the cloud but it's you know it's
totally up to you yes
yeah the question is whether this will
be available for marketplace
integrations no not the way that is
right now but you know it anything is
possible in the future
yes question oh the question is whether
this will always be mult tenant or it
can be yeah
right now this is envisioned to be
purely a multi tenant service the reason
is is that in order for us to provide
the malleus scale and flexibility that
we we have and kind of design it to be
basically exposed as an API service it
was necessary to make a multi tenant and
you know also economies of scale and all
the other great reasons people use the
cloud but yeah that's great questions
it's multi tenant yes
yeah so the first question is will the
hsn's be available in all regions the
the hsn's will be available globally and
it may or may not be available in all
regions right and so as I said before
it's not as easy as deploying the point
code and pushing out software because
there's a lot more process involved in
trying to get devices put into the day
center but we won't make sure that's
represented in the places where it's
most valuable to people and so you know
if there's a particularly area that you
guys care about a lot then I encourage
you to come and talk to me afterwards
and we can chat more about this and then
the second question was whether this can
be integrated cache core vault right it
already can it already is because
essentially hash core vault is already
integrate with our cloud kms and as you
just saw the only difference between
cloud kms and cloud HSM is a flag when
you actually create the key so to hash
your core vault it looks like dis like a
regular KMS key alright so the final
thing I want to talk about is the CM ek
integration or customer management
Christian Keys so this I think is a
really really great feature because a
lot of people put data into the cloud
right and they want to make sure that
they have some control over those cloud
services and right now what you can do
is that you can actually put data in
bigquery for example which is already GA
and you will be able to actually
associate the the encryption key that
ultimately protects the data in cloud
kms and consequently since cloud kms is
integrated cloud hsm in a cloud HSN key
and it's available for not only for
bigquery but also for compute engine
which is in beta also for cloud storage
and data proc ok and so what I'd like to
do now is I'd like to actually show you
a quick demo of how this works and how
simple this and so if you've already
used you know customer magic encryption
keys already then you know this is
probably something that you know you've
already gone through but I think it's
kind of neat ash you realized that
everything is being protected ultimately
by T and HSM if you can switch over
please
so what we're gonna do is we're going to
first start off back in the km/s console
and remember that when we actually use
customer magic Christian Keys who we're
talking about symmetric keys so let's go
and create a symmetric key here let's
just call it you know HSM demo whoops
demo sim key okay and it's gonna be a
symmetric key and we'll put in a
hardware cuz that's what you guys are
all here to look at and I'm gonna create
it okay
so HSN I apologize for all the keys but
so here's a key that we just created
right and I'm just gonna go through and
I'm gonna well I guess I don't need to
do this I'll do it anyways
so what I'll do is that I will now go to
create a new bucket in GCS and I'll just
say that this is HSM demo buck whoop
bucket - I might have already created a
bucket one cry regional US Central and
here's the thing in Advanced Settings
you can actually go right from the UI
and choose to say that I want this to be
matched by Google which is a default
encryption or you can choose to say that
I want to use custom magic encryption
keys and remember you know - it doesn't
care whether it's a KMS key or HSN key
right and so all you have to do is say
customer match key I'm gonna select the
key and just be faster I'm going to type
into actual key name right I do that and
it's nice enough to actually tell you
that in order for this to work the
service account associated with your
your instance of GCS needs access to
that key right and it will actually do
that for you so I'm going to hit grant
okay and so now I create that now I have
created this bucket whoops did I miss
oh I've already got - oh you're right
right now this always bugs me about this
I just want to talk to them there you go
yeah so I'm just gonna upload a file
it's gonna be a stupid file like sample
text you know I think that if I recall
this fall all it says is that this is
data let's see there we go a test day
for bucket right so now what I'm going
to do is I'm gonna actually go to kms
now and this key that we just created
this HSN demo sim key I'm gonna go there
and you can see that oops I'm gonna go
to the key itself and you can see on the
side here that it lists of permissions
and and sure enough you can see the fact
that you know the serfs account for GCS
was already added there and that was
done automatically so I'm just gonna
copy this just so I can add it later and
I'm gonna delete it right and so I have
now effectively deleted this access so
what what happens now so what happens is
that now when I go back to GCSE I try to
go and read any of the data in that
bucket right first of all GCSE does its
own permission check and says yeah you
guys are good now let me figure out
which data encryption keys I need to
decrypt and it's going to send that over
to kms and then kms is gonna go and see
those keys and say that okay let me see
if you're allowed to decrypt this and
it's gonna see that you're not allowed
to do this and it's gonna give you
access denied or at least that's what we
hope will happen
it usually takes around a minute or so
for the for the changes to propagate so
we might have to try this a couple times
so let's see if it works right now yeah
it works so we'll give it a few more
seconds
so the question was I just created deck
is there there deck model I actually
didn't create a deck I actually created
a keck so it's a data encryption key as
the keys I actually crypt the base data
and then above that the second level key
is a key encryption key when you talk
about customer magic encryption keys
you're always talking about that second
level key encryption key right and so
what happens is that in a normal case in
GCS bucket you have the bucket encrypted
with you know local keys and then it
goes up to the internal kms and the
scenic model that goes to cloud kms
instead so when you need to decrypt
those keys it actually goes in contacts
cloud kms and says can you please use
this specified key to encrypt my data
encryption keys correct correct so now
if I do this I think it's enough time
you get the permission tonight on cloud
KMS key it's really small I'm sorry but
that's why it says up there and people
in front could attest to it as well
right now basically I just prove that it
works the way it does right you now can
use your keys to actually have some
granularity around controller data so
now if you go back to cloud KMS and
decide that we're gonna add the
permission and we'll give it back the
encryption encrypt or decrypt or roll it
had that okay then we expect to see that
you know this is going to work again
right and sure enough it works again so
it's as simple as that right so you know
this is not really anything new if
you've been using CRISPR magic
encryption keys but it's just a quick
way of showing you that really nothing
changes you've just been able to use an
HSM key to secure data out in GCS and
looking at the time right now so we're
running out I was going to do the same
thing with bigquery but it's essentially
the same thing as well okay you can
actually just use bigquery associated
with HSM key and then remove permissions
and also and things start to break okay
so going back to the slides now to
summarize
what we've learned today is that you
know you you can actually use some of
the things that we provided now to help
meet your compliance objectives
previously before if you came to us and
said do you have anything that can help
me satisfy the requirements for a FIPS
140-2 ask you a level three device or
four crypto manager then we didn't have
an answer but we now can actually tell
you please use Cloud HSM the devices are
all FIPS validated okay you can meet
your security requirements around the
keys if you have more strict
requirements around saying that I want
to make sure that there's extra security
around some of the keys I point the
cloud you know there's an option for you
and also because it's a fully managed
service and I'd like to stress this you
don't have to worry about any anything
around your key management I'm sorry you
only have to worry about your key
management not around your HSM
management ok and finally you can now
actually go and use it for a lot more
things you know you have that CA that
you want to move up to the cloud because
you want it close to your workload now
you can do it right so it's all possible
for you and with that I think we're done
we have a couple minutes but I'd like to
thank everyone and if you have any
questions please let me know yes yeah
good question so the question is whether
we're we're concerning any any use with
corruption transit certificates and such
so right now we don't have something
like that that is an area that we're
interested in but the answer is right
now none any other questions yes
yeah that's a tricky question so the
question is some 95% tell timeframe by
which you they moved to beta yeah you
know I I'd love to tell you but
unfortunately I'm only allowed to say
it's coming soon and so I'll just say
coming soon yeah I'm sorry uh yeah it's
almost says keep watching the keep
watching our Google blog all right the
GCP blog and you know just keep
monitoring it hopefully you'll be
pleasantly surprised sometime soon yes
yeah please good question so can you set
some kind of variable that only permits
you to create HSM keys you you will be
able to do this through I am conditions
right so you can set a condition that
only allows you and authorizes you guys
you create keys with certain certain
flags right so this will be something
you'll be able to implement all right
great well thank you very much everyone
[Applause]
you
[Music]